dak Prescott with the shoulder injury
that was incurred on Sunday against the
Rams he was tackled by Clay Matthews
Chris Sims spotted it right away that
there's something wrong with that
shoulder and AC joint sprain in the
throwing arm of a quarterback not an
ideal situation and look I don't expect
that Prescott to say I don't know how
the hell I'm gonna get this done on
Sunday I don't expect anybody from the
Cowboys to tell us that the shoulder is
messed up if it's really messed up he's
not gonna throw much if at all in the
practices preceding the game which I
think says plenty and big cat from the
get-go and if I'm the Eagles I'm loading
up the box I'm taking away his ego
Elliott early and I want to see dak
Prescott throw the football and I want
to know what he's got before I adjust to
aggressively defending the passing game
I want him to prove that he can throw
the ball with that shoulder and also
there's a bull's-eye on that shoulder we
know how it goes in football there's
gonna be members of the Eagles defense
that are trying to hit that arm and hit
that shoulder and if dak Prescott runs
he's fair game yeah this is a
fascinating game to me because the
Eagles have not been playing well
they've won two in a row but they
haven't been playing well they lost the
Dolphins
they struggled with the Giants on Monday
Night Football they were down fourteen
three at half and guess what they that
game I know that the score will show
that it was a ten point game but that
that last touchdown came at the very
very end that Redskins game they didn't
blow him out they needed some heroics
they needed Carson Wentz to go eight for
eight on his final drive to win that
game so they have not been playing well
against some of the worst teams in the
NFL and then on the other side you have
the Dallas Cowboys who I you cannot
figure out what they are because they
have a roster that you put up with
pretty much any other roster in the NFL
and they have played games where they
have looked so so bad and then they come
out and play a game against the Rams
last week where everything worked
everything clicked you know the running
game is is going and that's really it if
the if the Cowboys can run the football
and they can build everything off of
Tony Pollard and Zeke Elliott and
play-action pass they look like a team
that could be playing in Miami in
February it's crazy to say but that is
what they that is their ceiling when
things start to roll so it's really like
the Eagles
if the
Cowboys had any kind of consistency I
would never even think about you know
the Eagles winning this game with the
way they've played recently but but we
have the Cowboys inconsistency that has
been in the back of our brains and
laying in against the Bears and laying
an egg against the bills and you know
losing to the Vikings and like there's
all these games where they haven't
stepped up in big-time moments so it's a
it's a fascinating game that I can't
even pretend to tell you what's gonna
happen they've already beaten the Eagles
37 to 10 this year which I think works
against the Cowboys in this spot because
there may be that sense
hey we're better than this team all we
have to do is show up and it'll go our
way if the Eagles can deliver a couple
of punches to the mouth early and it's
almost like that the Cowboys they slip
into a funk that they can't get out of
there and and what happens is and in the
bills game and in the Bears game they
score on the first drive they look great
they had that 17 play drive and as you
aptly pointed out in jest they used up
all their good plays on the first drive
of the game and they did they were
horrible after that that's what they
need to guard against there's that
moment somewhere middle the first
quarter through halftime where they just
kind of fall apart and with with the
Eagles at home if this game was in
Dallas I'd feel differently about it but
with the Eagles at home with Carson
Wentz playing as well as he has and with
that history that we've seen 2017 and
2018 different circumstances but 2017
they were written off going into the
playoffs they were underdogs at home in
two playoff games and they won both of
them last year they were written off
they were done they were four and six
they pulled it together down the stretch
this is Doug Peterson and Carter this is
Carson Wentz his chance to get everybody
to shut the hell up about Nick Falls and
they kept the wrong quarterback and
Carson Wentz is underachieving he has
even though it hasn't been against great
opposition which does give me pause he
has played well with this collection of
guys that they're there Vince pop
Ollie's right they had an open tryout
and they signed the guys who showed up
that's who's on the team for him to
throw the football to but but I think
the Eagles gonna win this game I just
feel like this is one of those moments
where Jason Garrett is going to do Jason
Garrett things the team is going to
stumble into that wilderness where all
of us
they don't know where they are and they
don't know how to get out of it and the
Eagles at home fueled by that rabid
crowd the Eagles are gonna win the game
and it's gonna set up a winning in
scenario next week for the Eagles when
they play the Giants I mean they can
still lose the division to the Cowboys
and that would be the ultimate Eagles
thing to beat the Cowboys and then go
and lose to the Giants next week but III
think the Eagles win and I think they
will win I think the Eagles gonna win
the division I do
Wow okay I'm taking the Cowboys in this
game and that's no disrespect to this
Eagles team and Carson Wentz because
they really just have no one left and
you know I joked that miles Sanders is
playing so well right now he's playing
he's playing so great this last few
weeks that he is gonna get injured
because that's just how the Eagles
season has gone like any time someone
steps up and looks like they can be a
fill-in guy they get hurt so that's the
Eagles season in a nutshell Mike they
have not played well since they played
the Bears first half because they
actually didn't play well in the second
half but since then they lost to the
Patriots in their offense was completely
shut down they lost the Seahawks at home
and the Seahawks tried to give that away
they lost the Dolphins in a game that
they needed to win and as I said before
they struggled with the Giants of the
Redskins so what recently tells you the
Eagles are gonna come out and be you
know able to play at the Cowboys level
or is it more than the indictment on the
Cowboys is what you're saying it's an
indictment on the Cowboys it's it's
Jason Garrett doing the ultimate Jason
Garrett move which is and and look you
laid it out perfectly this is a Super
Bowl roster could you imagine if the
Cowboys get in at eight and eight or
nine and seven and run the table against
all these double-digit win teams they
could do it but at some point Jason
Garrett is gonna drag them down and it
may come on Sunday
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports